qualité de service accueil
voilà le triptyque de la réussite de ce
premier salon lyonnais de métiers de
bouche
dizaines de visiteurs après si on avait
quasiment les plus contents je l'avais
eue mais je sais pas exactement on pense
à manger je ne sais pas encore ce que
l'on appelle aussi
un pari pour le métier
pareil pour lyon s'est rapidement relevé
gagner vous n'êtes jamais rien que
toujours pensé prochaine
et pour vous constructeur l'intérêt de
ce salon or pour nous constructeur la
cidse salon dépasse même les espérances
nous pensions que c'était un salon
régional de simulation la capitale lagat
3 nuits mais compte tenu les clients que
nous avons dû ils ont dépassé non
seulement la région la france
mais l'étranger et je peux dire que de
tous les salons de la monf s est
indiscutablement le mec il bouge il nous
a permis d'avoir le plus de contacts
avec l'ensemble de la profession
les pièces dresse la liste de l'usure du
navire les métiers de bouche c'est aussi
la gastronomie c'est donc les produits
frais est enfin l'alchimie culinaires ou
simplicité sa venue avant de faire sous
l'oeil des grandes toques démocratiser
c'est un salon qui fuit on voit les
visages souriant des glaciers qui ce
pacte a fait qu'ils font un concours
d'avoir motiver les gens c'est en même
temps désacraliser la cuisine culture
l'agroalimentaire de rhône alpes
représente 350 entreprises 25 mille
salariés
la chiffre d'affaires d'environ 20
millions de francs dans le car
l'exploitation l'artisanat qui est une
grande place dans ce secteur qui a en
main tous les atouts d'un meilleur
développement de l'artisanat est un des
piliers les plus importants de
l'économie actuelle et nous voulons
démontrer aussi que nos métiers sont des
possibilités d'emploi sont les
possibilités de dynamisme économique et
nous avons voulu montrer à travers son
salon il y encore des places pour les
jeux mais j'entends des jeunes qualifiés
dans tous les métiers il faut la
qualification prochain selon en 85